on opening day we were talking to each
other like who do you want to talk to
about it and this was the consensus
choice to let's get him on and he's kind
enough to join us here on opening day of
the 2022 season he is the founder and
ceo of jonboy media john boy himself how
are you sir i'm doing very well i feel
honored that i was the consensus pick
very much for having me you were that's
a fact that is an absolute fact so um i
don't know which way to go with this one
uh were you how nervous were you during
the lockout let's let's talk that one
first what do you think
yeah i i really thought they were going
to miss some games so i'm excited that
we got to 162.
it wasn't as ugly as i thought it was
going to be it was kind of just more
comical with the fake deadlines and one
side saying there's a deadline and the
other side saying we don't believe you
one side cancelling games and the other
side saying we don't believe you and
then they ended up uncanceling all the
games so uh we got to a good spot in the
end absolutely so uh tell me why the
dodgers are we why we should just watch
it why why the other 29 uh have a chance
or some some of them do walk me through
that one first well even if it is the
dodgers the whole way through and i do
think they're going to go paul to paul
first place and i do have them going to
the world series again i think that's
going to be exciting because i don't
know what arms are going to do it in la
they have a lot of young arms that are
going to impress us they don't have the
same starting pitching but they're just
so good other than that baseball's got
great parody so there's going to be some
team that surprises us and makes
playoffs then maybe makes a run and
hopefully the giants can give the
dodgers a run for their money again and
i think the ale
has four teams that have pretty similar
odds to
win the division
and then can do whatever they want in
the playoffs depending on who's healthy
and how they're rolling so the aoe
should be fun you know i and you know
when you talk about the al east it's
just it's it is hard to not choose the
rays
just because you know um
by the end of the day you know
you'll know that no matter what happens
they they they put the ball in play
they strike you out more
they
they've got arms that for days that
throw 100 miles an hour they've got a
manager who does not care what you think
about openers instead of starters and
anything like that everybody feels it
everyone hits it and
you know you might not have a whole
bunch of them on your fantasy team but
put them together and they're tough to
beat am i wrong about that one
i agree with you i was shocked when i
saw the odds and and a lot of the
experts are kind of down on the raise
this year i think
because
the names aren't there but the names are
never there you're basically just it's a
team of silhouettes you know they're
they're like roster didn't change during
the lockout when they changed all the
faces because you never know any of them
and they're gonna be there for four
years and they're gonna torment us
and then win and i i i chose the raids
to win the division and i said i didn't
even look at the roster i have no idea
who they are i'm with you i'm so with
you john boy i'm so 100 with you and
they're so frustrating and again you and
i come from the same pinstripe approach
here
because the yankees have got a gajillion
dollars and the rays you know
don't and the yankees have you know
monument park and the rays have all of
these rings in their stadium that you
need to know is gonna you know is
whether is in play or not you know so
um but by the end of the day they'll
just beat you anyway
um who is the surprise team then do you
think
in the american league
this year well the blue jays haven't
made the playoffs they didn't make the
playoffs last year it's not going to be
a surprise because everybody is is
choosing them and and they have a really
really complete roster the the lineup's
great the starting staff is top tier the
bullpen is really good maybe to fans
that aren't paying attention to the
off-season moves and the changes and and
just tune in on opening day and then get
caught up maybe they'll be a little
surprised that they are the favorite to
win the division barely
and some places don't have them as a
favor but a lot do
so i think that might be a surprise for
some people um
other than that i i really don't know i
think
there i think it's very top-heavy i
don't know if we're going to get a
surprise surprise team like i hope the
mariners
uh
catch some eyes in the west again and
actually make the playoffs because
they're young and they're fun they made
some moves to better their club and they
almost made the playoffs last year so
that might be a surprise team to to make
the dance but i wouldn't pick them to
win the world series so then who's your
american league team to face the dodgers
in the world series
i like the white sox and i say that
because i can't say another ali's team
and i don't really believe it's the
yankees and i can't give the red sox
rays or blue jays any love so that
leaves you with the white side
i like your process i like your process
very it's impressive john boy so
um let's get to the yankees it's it's
the pitching right they just you know
it's it's coal coal is way too
up and down for somebody that's supposed
to be locked in all the time for the
amount of money he makes
um right oh and then severino it's their
starters what what concerns you about
the yankees yeah it's it's an
interesting situation with the yankees
pitching because they finished last year
as a top five pitching staff in the
rotation and the bullpen according to
war and era plus and all those fun stats
but
cole carries a lot of that weight and if
he's hurt
uh like he was at the end of last year
or fatigued like he said then it dooms
you and
you can't have a hurt call on the road
in the wild card so
the staff can be really good if severino
is back and he's anything like the
severino we know and he showed signs at
the end of last year that'd be a really
really fun one-two punch so it is
you know opening day we are optimistic
and dreaming so i'm dreaming of severino
having a quality year i really like
jordan montgomery as a
three or four i think he's a grinder i
think he'll always have a couple games
that ruin his season-long era but he'll
he'll give the team a chance to win more
than he doesn't and hopefully taion can
step up so
the pitching was good last year was the
offense that was the problem uh
maybe it was flukey i'm not sure i do
love their bullpen i like the yankees
bullpen a lot they've really changed
their development development on the
pitching side in the minor leagues and
it's it showed john boye of john boy
media here on the rich eisen show
again one of the many things that you do
so well is show the game within the game
in such a way that is not only
entertaining and occasionally profane
but um
is is just straight up what what what's
being talked about and what's being
um perpetrated sometimes so uh are we
done with the spider attack is that all
done do you think or what
we have a very funny update mlb came out
and they said we are going to change the
process uh of umpires checking the
pitchers this year
because i think that's kind of them
sneakily admitting that it kicked back
up and if you look at a lot of pitchers
last year at the end of the year it
ticked back up so you go oh interesting
you're going to change the process what
do you think you have to do that's much
more intense to catch these guys and
they announced that they will now be
checking the pitcher's fingertips
what's going on there
what do you think what's going on there
seems like uh they might have maybe that
should have been the first place
from
instead of the belt instead of the belt
and the shoelaces and all that um
yeah they did they did belt hat
glove last year so i think a lot of
pitchers said okay i'll just put it
somewhere that's not those three places
so we will see we will see because at
the end of the in september last year a
lot of pitchers that definitely kicked
back up and you're like they might be
having again so now the umpires will
check their fingertips
and uh
hopefully it goes away because i don't
like all those
blights or the the doubt that it puts
into play
what is pitch com what the hell is this
thing can you explain it and what what
uh how this was it might actually
change the way that stein signs are
stolen in baseball jumble yeah so i i if
i have this correct i i i i'm not uh 100
but i i believe it's a it's a wristband
at the pitcher where the catcher wears
yes and he
he signals the pitch that he wants to
call to the pitcher
and the pitcher has a little speaker in
his hat that like whispers it to him
like siri and and they're allowed to
give two defensive players to hats as
well so you would guess it would be the
shortstop in the second baseman so they
know what pitch is being called and the
idea is to stop pitch dealing uh which
in theory is good and if that's all it
is i'm okay with it
uh you the first time a team taps into
the system and steals it electronically
i think you have to punish them like
fully fully punish them right away
because you know someone's gonna try but
in theory it should speed up the game
uh i i do love
i'm i'm pretty open to a lot of the
changes of speeding up the game making
it all more entertaining and all that i
do love watching the pitcher and catcher
communicate without words and shaking no
and the fake shakes uh zach grinky does
a lot of fake shakes where he shakes no
but he doesn't really mean it just to
fake out the batter so we'll lose a
little bit of that but
if if it takes away sign stealing and
and scheming and we get a more honest
approach i'm fine with that so it's in
the hat like i i can't wait to see how
this works and so if a shortstop and a
any in a second basement have it because
it from what i read it not only
communicates what the pitch is but the
location as well
and so and it works in english and
spanish as well that like let's just say
there's 6 000 fans in a stadium because
a team stinks or it's you know
12 30 at night and they went through a
three-hour rain delay is it possible
somebody's leading off a second base and
they hear something in the ear they've
communicated you know the shortstop like
is that entirely possible
i'd love to test it out and see because
how loud is it right can they not can
they hear it if the crowd is loud is now
football come into play where you're you
know screaming so the pitcher can't hear
the call because then they'll just
revert back to their fingertips so that
weirded me out when they said it was a
robot saying it like why wouldn't it
just be like a
or you know
i don't know it seems like a little buzz
would be better but to have someone
whisper to you i think it would throw me
off my game if i had a robot talking
yeah you know i'm sometimes my guy
brockman gets in my ear and he sounds
very robotic and it throws me off a
little bit too so yeah
so uh john boy uh walk me through your
process how do you decide what deserves
one of your fame breakdowns or not walk
me through like say oscar night what
that was like for you uh
oh so my baby was asleep already i had
put him down and i was uh on the couch
yes by myself and for that one it was
well i got tagged in it a bunch because
uh at first people thought it was going
to be a lip reading situation because
they muted it in the u.s
so i my twitter blew up and then
and then uh the other footage came out
there was one from australia
that was not bleeped and then there's
one from uh japan which had it uh
uncensored uh what will smith yelled but
also had like the japanese overdub and
they were all three of those were going
around so
i thought it would be beneficial to
mix the three so that's what i did i
combined the three so it's one fluid no
japanese overdub the austral the actual
words and then i kind of just you know
walked through
why will why he took offense and and
then kind of pointed out some funny
stuff that i noticed and uh yeah once i
realized there's three different clips
going around and it'd probably be
helpful if i just combined them for
people right knowing that it was hot and
if i
i that that was a breakdown that i if i
made it the next day i don't think it
gets as much attention but i was able to
make it within the hour and i got 20
million views
it's amazing 20 million views
in half a day across twitter facebook
and youtube it went nuts so do you
you're cutting this yourself like you're
like i i gotta do this like on the spot
or you gotta tell me i grabbed all the
footage went down to my office in the in
the basement and pieced it together and
edited it posted it
that is truly the most i still can't
believe he slapped him i still can't
believe that actually happened
john boy no it's uh a lot of people
thought it was fake but now the
repercussions are coming down and you
think i hope i don't think people think
it's fake anymore what's your favorite
one you've done for baseball
which one do you think is the best one
you've done your breakdown we're up to
like a thousand now so that's it's tough
uh people there's ones that you know the
boone's speech the savages in the box
still cracks me up every time i hear it
but that's all him i didn't do much
um
there's some good lip readings i always
loved gabe kepler when he was on the
phillies because he was kind of so
earnest in his uh arguments with umpires
whenever i can tackle the the lip
reading and really think i got it that's
fun um
let's see the amir garrett fight one
that's a while back but everybody enjoys
that last year i had the when scherzer
got checked for sticky stuff and then
joe gerardi was yelling at
uh across the dugout and they had to rub
the umpire's fingers through his hair
that was really fun
i remember i remember that one he's just
like you got to be kidding me that was a
good one yeah did you ever get any blow
back somebody was like really pissed
that you you tapped into something that
that actually happened and um
and they didn't want the the john boyce
lip reading treatment spotlight placed
on it does that happen with you no i no
i haven't i whenever we interview
players or meet players sometimes
they'll say like oh you did one and i
always asked did i did i get it right
and usually they're like yeah i try not
to
ever really put someone on full blast i
think now i know people watch them so
it's it's
trends more towards humor than critique
but no i have it i'm sure there's been
players that haven't enjoyed a video or
just you know a bad moment there was
that uh pirates first baseman will craig
who had one of the worst blunders ever
and i made a video on it and you know
just this is one of the worst blunders
ever so i'm sure he didn't
watch it or enjoy that it was made but
what are you gonna do you mean running
somebody back to home plate like he's
got him in a rundown
yeah yeah that's a first bet
a grounder first running him back
running him back to home plate like like
a that was little league stuff that was
unbelievable
it was very bizarre could have just
stepped on first oh my god
uh all right before i let you go uh what
what is what are we not talking about
what's coming this season what are you
hearing about what do you think is going
to be because i i didn't think
you know we would be talking spider tack
in the middle of the year last year uh
until obviously a couple of games got
played but what what are you hearing
what can you what can you tell us
anything on that front john boyce it's
been such a crazy offseason that we have
we had so many moves um
i don't know like it doesn't seem like
there's a big target in the off season
right now that we know like hey this
guy's gonna get traded for come the
all-star break around there so
i'm hoping that
it's really the nle's and and the al
east are kind of really top-heavy a
bunch of teams good baseball
i don't i don't have any uh you know
drama that i am aware of besides the
baseball games well one thing i think
one thing i think you should keep an eye
on if you if i may and i think you will
anyway but uh the umpires trying to
figure out how to announce to the crowd
what they've actually decided for the
first time they're being forced to
just like every other ref in sports or
official in sports explain to the crowd
they don't they
what they've decided to
adjudicate once replay is over they
can't just you know give one sign and
grunt at a base and just leave it at
that anymore i i yeah 15 years later mlb
finally did it i mean right so like
which they're gonna be some umpires that
just won't be able to handle the
explanation factor or anything like that
or miss the camera or something like
that i think yeah there's a lot of like
you know they don't have their uh
stage-ready voice
it's gonna be it's gonna be funny to
hear some of them stumble through it and
and also sometimes the the upstairs um
gets it wrong and then they have to be
the one that tells everyone
that
you know what to me it was him
that's what they tell the players
i mean
i've lip read that before they say hey
upstairs made this call i don't know
i was just saying the other day i'm
upset this has happened after joe west
retires
you know
you know denying us one extra way for
him to communicate to the fans that he
doesn't really care to communicate with
them it's just like that that that's
that disappoints me that he's i would
bet you when he read the headline he he
thought about coming out back out of
retirement
just to show that he's got a mic
that's right just to show his disdain
verbally you know for everybody
uh john boy congrats on all your
remarkable success and look for my call
i'd love to keep in touch with you and
just get your unique perspective on this
sport i think it's valuable and uh and
and unique and entertaining and thank
you appreciate it
awesome thank you for having me you got
it that's uh john boy of john boy media
i follow him everybody pretty much has
to i think in order to be online hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here